é muito gratificante está com vocês meu
nome é walsh nairy minha grande paixão é
a criação da escola de teatro no palco
da vida
a primeira escola de arte da região da
leopoldina zona norte e rio de janeiro
vem comigo vamos fazer um vôo pelos céus
do ceará
em 1900 e alguma coisa uma cegonha que
me deixou na cidade simples chamada
tabuleiro do norte
eu nasci em uma família de sete irmãos
aos cinco anos de idade e meu pai deixou
minha mãe e minha mãe reuniu todo esses
meninos e falou que a gente tinha que
sobreviver àquela questão
ela deu uma missão para cada um alguns
foram graxa
minha mãe foi fazer faxina no final da
tarde ea pegar o osso do assunto
eu com os outros irmãos foi catar lixo
pra comer eo restante para trazer para
casa no final do dia amanhã reunirá
todos os meninos para fazer a famosa
sopa de carne
nossa única refeição do dia eu como sou
muito curioso ficava esperando um
momento que parecia carne nunca pareceu
a carne no meu próprio mas eu posso
falar que minha mãe criou uma coisa
fundamental a mágica a mágica que fez eu
me apaixonar pelo circo porque todo o
circo que chegava na cidade
eu saía correndo atrás do circo para
levantar o circo os palhaços se
maquiando e me apaixonar e eu corria pra
fila para tentar vender a maçã do amor
pra assistir o máximo de espetáculo de
graça e no final eu chegava os palhaços
e dizia que eu faço pra fazer parte
desse universo ele dizer que minha mãe
tinha que dar para o cerco eu corri até
amanhã de manhã me dá pro circo
minha mãe nunca me deu por ser com uma
duas e eu só queria entender isso
muitos anos depois com todos vocês aqui
presente
às vezes a vida pode dar esses
provocações de pulos porque eu cheguei
em um momento pra minha e tentar pra
mamãe eu quero ser aquilo que os homens
são ali dentro da televisão univirr ou
pra mim e disse menino isso é coisa de
gente rica
ainda bem que eu não sabia diferente
entre rico e pobre todos vocês aqui o
que vocês fariam com 25 reais
eu vou dizer o que eu venho fazendo
estou transformando a 25 anos atrás
quando deu aquela loucura os 17 anos e
queria ser artista eu cheguei pra minha
mãe de simoninha não deixa morrer não me
ajuda a realizar o meu sonho eu pedi a
ela 25 reais
ela correu a cidade inteira atrás
levando sim não muito não mas depois
muito tempo ela conseguiu 25 reais
ela colocou um pacote de biscoito doce e
minha rede
eu gosto da minha própria bolsa botei um
único livro com tudo isso pronto eu
percebi que faltava o elemento principal
para buscar meu sonho a carona junto com
a amiga minha chamada jesuíta convênios
a cidade durante um mês os caminhoneiros
sozinho pra são paulo finalmente depois
de muito não alguém vinha o rio de
janeiro é esse que eu vou
foi o momento mais difícil para mim o
momento de me despedir da minha mãe e
meus irmãos um final de tarde eu dei um
beijo em cada um deles
e na hora de dar um beijo de manhã eu vi
que ela chorava muito no caminhão e uma
coisa olhar para trás porque se eu
desistir deve ter chorado em cima desse
caminhão durante um dia cheguei no rio
de janeiro às quatro da madrugada na
ceasa do rio não era o rio que eu via na
novela eu falei caminhoneiro que não é o
rio de janeiro eles e eu disse não não é
esperei das seis da manhã às seis da
manhã meu primeiro destino central do
brasil rio de janeiro eu nunca tinha
visto tanta gente indo e vindo tanto
barulho de carro ao mesmo tempo eu vou
dizer o que mais me fascinou foi quando
eu olhei pra cima eu nunca tinha visto
prédio tão alto e deve ter ficado com
tantas janelas uma duas três quatro
cinco seis eu disse um dia eu vou morar
aqui meu segundo destino com endereço
que manhã tinha conseguido com a amiga
dela que um filho morava na rua seu dedo
à rocinha me mandou para a rocinha
depois de muito tempo não pela rocinha
procurando rua terruá sei nada de
encontrar o endereço finalmente bateu na
porta eu bato
desmaiado eu desmaiei porque eu estava
dois dias comendo biscoito com doce
eu estava com fome
minha vida começou no rio de janeiro
depois dessa sopa os 25 reais que minha
mãe me deu eu tinha que fazer eles se
multiplicar
é a única oportunidade que tinha de
realizar meu sonho eu podia voltar minha
vida certo eu decido a padaria lá
embaixo e comprei um pacote de pão para
poder sobreviver os primeiros meses de
27 pontos sete pedaços todo dia com uma
fatia de pão com um copo de água da
torneira e aí eu fui sobrevivendo e
curioso e perguntei foi preciso
trabalhar que é preciso comer e onde que
bate oportunidade no rio de janeiro aí
me falaram que copacabana em copacabana
que eu vi na favela me manda pra
copacabana em copacabana terra dos sims
copacabana terra dos não foi onde eu
levei mais não eu levei não do arpoador
princesa isabel da princesa isabel
voadora tanto não chegou o momento disse
deus muito um português depois de mandar
ou não me chamo magrinho vem cá eu corri
até ele e disse que começa agora ele
disse não começa amanhã 8 da manhã no
dia 8 da manhã 6 eu já estava lá 6 7 7 6
e 7 40 me apresentei
ele me deu um balde um gol de uma
vassoura se eu comecei eu comecei
lavando o banheiro mais uma vez e
banheiro com muita determinação eu
deixei aquilo brilhando banheiro porque
minha mãe tereza me ensinou uma coisa
fundamental
qualquer coisa que eu fosse fazer eu
fizesse com brilho e capricho e foi o
que eu fiz foi promovido foi promovido a
atendente de balcão para vender minha
filha era sempre enorme tinha sempre
muita gente eu não sei se minha fila
ficava grande ou vendendo porque eu
sorria ou porque eu dava as gramas tudo
errado porque não entendia de matemática
e nessa padaria surgiu também o primeiro
amigo que me deu oportunidade o severino
paraibano que diz assim o aval para
surgir no teste aí teste pra lavar prato
eu quero isso testador famoso
restaurante na época chamado lefan
restaurante francês bonito nome difícil
né e aí eu fui fazer esse teste um
caldeirão era enorme
eu entrei nesse caldeirão pra lavar eu
lavava tatá
deixei também brilhando que minha mãe
tinha três copos em casa de alumínio só
mas ela lavava e sescoop que dava pra
gente pentear o cabelo no copo
fui promovido no restaurante virei
lavador de prata oficial
e aí nesse restaurante eu conheci uma
coisa que foi amor à primeira vista eu
conheci uma carne chamada filé nenhum e
foi a 1 foi o olhei a gente se deu muito
bem uma carne macia
depois disso também eu tive o privilégio
de morar num restaurante onde eu dormia
nas mesas enrolava com histórias o
restaurante pra acalentar meu frio e
depois que eu saí da favela mas também o
restaurante me deu uma das grandes
prioridades da minha vida o meu grande
anjo da guarda
chamado de milho kazuo yoshino o coronel
do corpo de bombeiro que lhe deu a
possibilidade de fazer faxina na casa
dele para pagar meus estudos meu segundo
grau minha faculdade minha pós-graduação
em arte então o restaurante me deu tudo
isso de bom e depois disso quando se faz
teste é quando você termina a faculdade
surgiu os testes oportunidade que matou
meu primeiro teste não podia ser
diferente do rio genética é grande com
miguel falabella para poder contar a
vida de carmen miranda eu falei pra
vocês meus dotes musicais não são dos
melhores mas que matou 70 sempre
arriscando mimando com escala no final
de tarde chegou na escala é uma fila tão
grande tem dores 400 pessoas tentando 15
vagas
eu chego lá o miguel fica lhe disse vai
cantar o que eu falo vou cantar morena
tropicana alceu valença e começou a
testar aquele momento eu comecei morena
tropicana ele falou que eu estava fora
do tom mas eu mais uma vez a morena
tropicana é ter um sapato você está
totalmente fora do tom está chegando a
pianista gestão eu paguei uma aula de
música e eu vou cantar eu vim aqui pra
cantar e eu comecei será minha terceira
tentativa eu tinha que tentar fazer
diferente então mistura um pouco de
claudia leitte ivete sangalo e comecei
cantar e coreógrafa ao mesmo tempo e eu
comecei morena tropicana eu quero seu
sabor e aí é claro que eu não passei
nesse teste eu não passei eu não passei
mas eu falo para vocês eu fui notícia no
outro dia nos principais jornais do rio
de janeiro um chat
e virei amigo do miguel falabella e às
vezes gente
a oportunidade vem disfarçada de
obstáculos e depois disso muito tempo
depois eu tive um grande privilégio e
virar toda grande emissora de televisão
do país a rede globo uma grande ajuda de
um amigo sá maristela veloso nelson
fonseca e minha carreira vem sendo
coroada com os trabalhos de ator pela
autora elizabeth jhin
então eu venho tendo essa possibilidade
eu realizei meu sonho de ser ator na
cidade grande mas é quando se realiza o
sonho você fica zenon
se deus colocou isso em mim é pra mim
poder multiplicar e é amigo falou pra
mim o seguinte quando ele me deu
oportunidade de estudar e de silval eu
vou te ajudar a estudar mas o retorno é
você ajudar o máximo de pessoas
possíveis
e é o que eu estou fazendo e aí como
nasce o projeto no palco da vida
o projeto no palco da vida nasceu de um
convite que recebi para dar aula para 50
meninos do complexo do alemão em 2007 eu
fui dessa oficina oficina fez muito
sucesso porque os nomes que o potencial
de voz corpo vontade eu me encontrei
aqueles meninos com o menino que eu era
no interior do ceará a vontade de ser
alguma coisa
foi estudando e terminou oficina eles
queriam continuar e uma das meninas
sugeriu o quintal da casa dela em olaria
eu disse é um tópico ou de forma
totalmente gratuita fomos pro quintal
mas era tanto menino e simplesmente o
quintal não cabia um grupo ficava em
pneu furado no muro enquanto fazer ao
outro assistir então que zé é um espaço
pequeno pra muita gente só foi
multiplicando de menino e eu sonhando
querendo mais querem uma casa que era um
espaço que tivessem livros que pudesse
correr solto quadro até passando pela
rua anos houve um casarão antigo
eu olhei pra esse casarão disse maggi no
palco da vida que meninos correndo com
biblioteca livre é tão bonito mas eu
tive coragem eu fui descobrir como
conseguir aquele espaço corria atrás do
proprietário e buscar um amigo meu
escritor francisco azevedo e desse tipo
me ajuda a levantar esse sonho aí ele
manteve os seis primeiros aluguéis do
palco da vida virou um palco de
transformações
o palco da vida vem fazendo dez anos com
aulas totalmente gratuita bem premiado
no brasil
mundo transformando vidas e ao número 1
vai entrar no palco da vida é a aula da
faxina aula de humildade um balde um com
uma vassoura para conhecer o espaço e aí
começa a acontecer no teatro da vida têm
biblioteca riquíssima de 9 mil livros de
arte antropologia sociologia temos a
videoteca rara do teatro brasileiro de
cinema contando toda a história né dos
primeiros filmes e obras de arte na
parede para provocar o sensorial dos
meninos e o melhor que tem da arte da
vida para dali eles fazem voos mais
consistente mas o que tem mais de
interessante no palco da vida é a
transformação é a transformação das
pessoas
a dona ana uma senhora de 80 anos que
faz aula de música teatro quando ela
chega no palco da vida chega com muitas
dores no corpo e quando ela termina às
aulas ela chega e israel quando termina
a aula aqui quando eu saio minhas dores
homem do corpo a pessoa recebe afeto
amor oportunidade tudo muda na vida da
pessoa tem história do ilha também cuida
da região do complexo alemão quando
entrou tinha 14 anos
muito agressivo porque não tinha pai
pensou que através de agressividade era
a resposta dele para o mundo foi
apresentado o livro foi apresentado à
câmara e possibilidades
o joelho é um dos coordenadores do
projeto no palco da vida vale a pena art
quando ela entra na via vai
transformando ea história da junta a
joana tem necessidades especiais
pois é ela tem necessidades especiais
mas ela se apaixonou pelo carimbó e
transformou o nosso campo de trabalho
numa verdadeira dança e torna agente
especial para buscar sonhos e não vê
limites nas possibilidades de sonhar
a joana exemplo diária para a gente
continuar acreditando em um momento
especial quando você tem um sonho você
primeiro faz um jeito esse sonho ganhar
formas nesta não pode só e pinta você
idealiza esse sonho na cabeça eu
realizei o meu lar
quando eu estava lá no interior eu pedi
uns vinte e cinco reais amanhã eu vim
buscar uma escola para estudar e acabei
criando uma escola no rio de janeiro e
aí eu pintei o meu sonho eu sou muito
tempo atrás
a ida do lápis de cor e esse desenho foi
idealizado né
pintado por mim uma madrugada com muita
vontade e acreditando que um dia isso
pudesse realizar é é aquela é esses
momentos que às vezes se tornam mágicas
na vida né
e até a fachada do espaço da casa que se
transformou isso aqui
essa é a escola
mas nada disso teria sido possível se
esses anjos é não tivesse surgido na
minha vida dessas pessoas que pegaram na
minha mão acreditar em mim naquele
menino eu adoro ritmo estivesse aqui na
platéia ela entender que valeu a pena as
faxinas para minar o caderno o embrulho
depom quantas vezes eu escrevi pra dar
certo aqui e ali para continuar
escrevendo quando faltava o caderno ea
gente tem que sonhar com determinação
com o pé no chão mas com a cabeça nas
nuvens
eu acho que não existe o impossível eu
posso falar pra vocês aqui em fazer mais
o que é carne mas eu posso falar isso
aqui
nitidamente que é possível sim tem uma
outra imagem que ela funciona com uma
muleta na minha vida eu sou pequenininho
segurando na mão de manhã com o pé no
chão
essa imagem é o círculo com ela em todos
os momentos cruciais da minha vida e
nunca perdeu o elo com minha rua pra mim
nunca perdeu o elo com o meu de onde eu
vim por mais que esteja às vezes no meio
das estrelas é viver nesses momentos que
eu sempre sonhei
eu não posso esquecer da música minha
mãe não posso esquecer de onde vêm os
irmãos porque só assim a gente humaniza
ea gente consegue olhar para o outro de
igual para igual e quando você realiza
um sonho acho que você toca é s fica
mais próximo de deus o deus que você
acredita não importa é você começa a ter
uma outra conexão com o universo e eu
acho que você tem que ser um fluxo tem
que ser um fluxo do amor do afeto das
possibilidades eu acredito muito que tem
uma energia nessa escola sua energia eu
escolhi me peguei na mão dele vem mas eu
não fiquei feliz em fazer o meu eu quero
que esses meninos invada o mundo com
arte com amor que eles têm de melhor
para poder transmitir para o mundo e
quando eu saí de lá do interior minha
mãe me deu esse caderninho aqui e aí
como é um momento especial tem uma frase
que veio aqui que eu queria compartilhar
eu acho muito especial também para mim
eu acho que depois sair daqui hoje é
impossível dizer que algum sonho
possível
não tem como por favor é mover-se mesmo
ea frase isso é melhor lançar se na luta
mesmo exposto aos insucessos do que
permanecer na penumbra com aqueles que
não conhece nem vitória nem derrota
muito obrigado